sur la totalité du réseau routier
français
la vitesse sera limitée à 100 km à
l'heure étant entendu que les sections
des routes nationales où la vitesse est
déjà limitée à 110 kilomètres à l'heure
resteront à cette vitesse de 110
kilomètres à l'heure et que d'autres
sections à mesure de leurs améliorations
pourront être portés à cette même
vitesse de 110 à l'heure avant que vous
ne preniez la route avec votre ceinture
de sécurité
obligatoirement bouclé à partir de
dimanche
voici une illustration de ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire et des sanctions qui vous
guette désormais vous devez respecter
les stops
même s'il n'ya apparemment personne
si vous grillé le stop vous risquez un à
quatre mois de suspension du permis de
conduire et une forte amende doublée en
troisième position en franchissant en
plus une ligne continue
ça équivaut au retrait systématique du
permis pendant six mois si vous n'êtes
pas un état d'ébriété
et si vous n'avez pas provoqué
d'accident sinon la suspension peut
aller jusqu'à 30 mois
le franchissement d'un feu rouge le
refus d'obtempérer aux sommations d'un
gendarme ou d'un policier suspension du
permis de 1 à 20 mois plus la main
n'oubliez pas que les routes sans
panneaux sont toutes limitées à 100
lever le pied
si votre aiguille a tendance à
s'orienter vers la droite pour les
routes à panneaux rien changé il suffit
de respecter ces panneaux les gendarmes
et les crs seront d'ailleurs très
nombreux sur les routes pour les grands
départs et ils auront leur radar les
excès de vitesse peuvent provoquer le
retrait du permis pour quatre mois sur
les routes limitées à 100 beaucoup
d'automobilistes ne savent pas comment
ils doivent se comporter pour dépasser
un véhicule roulant à 90 kilomètres à
l'heure un camion par exemple s'il
dépasse le sang risque-t-il d'être en
infraction
une certaine tolérance sera admise
lorsqu'il s'agira dépasser les véhicules
isolé roulant en dessous de la vitesse
limite
bien entendu il faut pas que cette
tolérance venu à des abus c'est à dire
que on en profite pour doubler des fils
continue de véhicules ou les véhicules
qui roulent déjà à la vitesse de 100 km
heure mais cette mesure de tolérance
devraient faciliter les choses
on pourra rouler à combien de temps à
plus de 100 kilomètres à l'heure
le temps de doubler le véhicule et de se
rabattre c'est à dire quelque chose
assez bref pour faciliter la fluidité et
la sécurité du trafic et ne pensez vous
pas que
de fait d'imposer 100 kilomètres à
l'heure uniformément risque de créer de
longues files de voitures qui ne sera
pas possible de doubler
écoutez je ne pense pas il faut bien
voir que les files de voitures résulte
essentiellement des grands départs en
week-end des grands départs pour les
vacances et qu'elles se produisent tous
les ans qu'il y ait ou qu'il n'y ait pas
limitations de vitesse je prends
contraire que la mesure de tolérance qui
était admise pour le dépassement devrait
éviter ces longues files que l'on craint
et qui ne sont pas en fait une
conséquence de la limitation de vitesse
vous savez tout de même que certains
camions roulent déjà à 100 kilomètres à
l'heure
alors est ce qu'il sera possible de les
doubler
aucun camion n'a le droit de rouler à
100 km heure avec les poids lourds font
l'objet de limitations particulière à 80
km heure pour la plupart d'entre eux
donc je pense que le problème est
d'abord que ces poids lourds respecte
les limitations de vitesse et à ce
moment là les dépasse on devrait pouvoir
s'effectuer sans trop de fumée
de toute manière c'est une mesure
nouvelle il faut voir ce qu'elle donne
je pense dans trois mois on pourra tirer
les premières conclusions
j'espère que sur le plan des accidents
ce seront des goncourt au positif